This video is made possible by brilliant.
You'll learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you would like to learn more about them right now,
it goes a brilliant.org forward slash biographics.
You'll also find a link in the description below.
He was America's first and most celebrated western anti hero.
It was claimed that he kills 21 men,
one for every year of his young life,
and the press portrayed him as a ruthless,
psychotic wild.
I kill it.
The reality was that billy,
the kid,
was none of these things.
I mean this week's biographics,
we go in such of the real early,
there is uncertainty as to the birthplace of the child who would become a
believer kit.
Most historians believe that was the slums of New York City,
and the year was 18,
59.
His birth name was Henry Mccarty and he was the son of Irish immigrants who had
come to America to escape the devastating effects of the Irish potato famine.
His mother's name was Katherine,
but we know nothing about his father except that he died when Henry was an
infant.
When Henry was around six and his mother joins the post civil war exodus,
do the West in such.
If the batter life that had so far alluded them in the new world,
they drained a wagon train and undertook the arduous journey over the Oregon
trail.
They go as far as Indianapolis,
Indiana,
there,
Karen and Matt had married a man by the name of William Harrison.
Trim and trim had dreams of striking it rich in the gold mines to the southwest.
And soon the makeshift family had relocated to silver city,
New Mexico,
New Mexico in the early eighties,
seventies was like a foreign country to immigrants from the east.
It was mainly peoples by Mexicans and native Americans.
The entire culture and religion was very different to what most Americans were
used to.
French,
Spanish and Navajo were more likely to be spoken in English.
And most houses were maces carved into the sides of rock formations.
In this Hodgepodge of cultures,
violence was commonplace.
What many newcomers from the east would have recoiled at such an environment,
a young,
uh,
Henry Annacarty.
He embraced it,
immersed himself in the Mexican culture,
spending most of his time in the Hispanic part of town.
By the time he was a teenager,
he could speak fluent Spanish and could even pass for native Mexican with
Sombrero and pawn shape.
Whenever that was a public Mexican social events,
Henry would be that often with his mother.
The two would dance,
the fandango together and talk easily with the Mexican elders.
Unlike most of the Europeans in town,
Henry showed respect to the locals exhibiting a formal politeness to the older
generation,
which one have a lot of praise.
He was remembered by the Hispanic community,
is a charming boy who was always happy.
The humor was cruelly snatched from Henry's life when at the age of 15,
he suffered the loss of his mother.
Katherine had been suffering from tuberculosis for some time and it was hoped
that the dry air of New Mexico would say condition,
but it wasn't to be.
Catherine died in 1874,
believing henry and the possession of his stepfather,
William Antrim.
Andrew,
however,
had no intention of being tied down with a teenage.
Boys look after he promptly abandoned 10 read,
leaving town,
and more fertile gold diggings,
so with the age of 15,
Henry was left on his own to fend for himself in a dangerous frontier town.
Henry now had to live off his wits.
He spends his time hanging around the saloons and prostitutes on the cds sign of
town,
sleeping in back alleys and boarding houses and running errands to pay his way.
He soon became involved in minor criminal activity and meeting up with a hoodlum
by the name of some railroad.
Jack Henry was recruited as a lookout.
Well Jack,
Rob's local businesses.
One of them was the local Chinese laundry.
Things fall apart when a loaded revolver,
that jacket sterling from the laundry,
was found in Henry's possession.
Boy was arrested and thrown into the local jail.
It was while sitting in that tiny jail salvage Henry made a fateful decision.
He could have sat and waited for the circuit judge to come to town and try his
case,
but that may have taken months.
Instead,
he decided to escape.
In doing so,
he honed the skill that would serve him to good effect.
Many times over the next five years that was getting people to underestimate his
abilities,
henry talked his God into allowing him to come out of his cell for a short
period in order to stretch his legs.
He was still confined to the jail house and the door to the outside world was
security knocks,
but that was also a chimney.
Why does God was out of the room and we've managed to squeeze this slight frame
up,
the suit covered escape hole and onto the roof and then into the town plaza.
By the time it was discovered that he had escaped,
he was free of silver city and en route to Arizona carrying no food supplies and
without a horse.
Henry displayed an incredible physical and mental strength in crossing the
desert plains of the southwest.
He quickly learns that Hampton live off the land,
is foraging where he could and steaming wearing must.
The 16 year old wanted fugitive,
made it across 500 miles of desert before stumbling into a remote army outpost
in eastern Arizona.
Gold Camp grads here,
he managed to find employment as a cook on a local ranch after hours.
He drifted to the local town where he took the gambling and hustling in the
saloons,
the men and he was now associated with included some hardened criminals and they
quickly showed him the ropes.
Before long,
he was participating in stealing horses
outside of his ranch duties and isn't nefarious nighttime activities.
Young Henry,
it founds the time to perfect his skills with a firearm.
He had managed to buy a revolver and quickly discovered an innate ability to
wield it.
With this skill came instant respect for those around him.
Within a year of escaping the jail cell in silver city,
Henry had developed into a character of note among the thugs in the Arizona
territory.
He wore a brightly colored scarf around his neck and walks with the self
assuredness of a man many years older than his only 17 years,
and it was at this time that people will begin to call him the kid.
It was August the 17th,
18,
77 when the kid went from small time crook to hardened killer.
The local blacksmith was a bully by the name of Frank k hill on that nice while
drinking in a saloon.
Cahill had his sights set on Henry and he was throwing insults at the kid when
the kid called him a son of a bitch.
Okay.
He'll jumped him and proceeded to pounds him on the saloon floor.
Pins underneath the bigger man.
The kid managed to free his six shooter.
He shows cahill in the stomach and then quickly it slid out from under him
leaving the blacksmith to die.
He hightailed it out of town on a stone and horse and headed back to New Mexico.
Now I wanted fugitive for the crime of murder.
The kid changed his name to William h dot Bonnie.
He wandered across the vast open spaces relying on the hospitality of Hispanic
ranches to provide him with a meal or a place to lay his head.
Meanwhile,
New Mexico was being targeted by big shot land speculators from back east.
They sold the mostly barren territory,
is a golden opportunity for speculation,
and they began buying up land parcels from Hispanic settlers,
usually prices that were manifestly unfair to the seller.
Those who didn't want to sell that lands like they were going to find themselves
facing fondant prosecution.
Soon the eastern entrepreneurs had wrested control of every industry in the
state from mining to the castle industry,
and even the railroads.
The largest county in New Mexico was Lincoln,
which covered nearly a fifth of the entire territory.
It was there in 18,
78.
There's a war broke out that would have a profound effect on the remaining years
of beneath the kid's life.
In the late 18 sixties,
a couple of Irish immigrants by the names of Lawrence Mathy and James Dolan has
bought up the majority of Lincoln County and turned it into a huge cattle ranch.
They had secured extremely large military contracts to supply beef to fort
stands in the Murphy Dolan monopoly,
and Lincoln County was called the house and it was fiercely protected by battens
of thugs known as the seven rivers gang.
They operated from a huge wooden building in the middle of the Lincoln township
and controlled every business in town in 18,
77,
the house monopoly over Lincoln County was challenged first in court and then on
the range by a Scottish born local attorney by the name of Alexander Mcswain,
teaming up with a lie.
It was a 23 year old,
recently arrived at British actress by the name of John Turn,
stall with a seemingly unending supply of funds to the store,
was intent on creating his own castle empire in the county.
In this quest,
he enjoyed the support of the most successful and famous cattle baron in the
entire country.
John Chism tunstall began to recruit employees not only to work the council,
but also the protection that he knew would be needed when he came up against the
house.
What are you,
Bonnie?
In Lincoln County in mid 18,
77 and immediately proceeded to do what he did best and that was steal horses in
short order.
He was caught and thrown in jail.
It just so happens that the man he had been wrestling horses from.
Well,
that was John Tunstall when the Englishman confronted the teenage outlaw and
they declined to press charges and steady off of the kid a job as a member of
the regulators,
the team of cowboys,
that whereas protection squad,
billy,
he grabbed this off,
uh,
with both hands in Johnstown stole.
He had found a man who would give them a fair break.
He said this,
if his employer Tom Stole,
was the only man who treated me like I was decent on white.
The kid joins a group of men will older than him as he learns the work of a
cowboy.
It was a long,
arduous,
often backbreaking work and they slept sounds with the castle on the range for
the Betas of the house,
Muffy and,
and the idea of an upper crust Englishman moving in on that territory was
thinkable like the kid's parents that escape the famine back in Ireland and
deeply resented the English over their unwillingness to provide relief.
Now,
having found that new life in the new world where they again to be plagued by
the power and the money of the English well,
that's something that they would never allow to happen.
Nothing and Dolan's power extended to control of the legal system that Lincoln
county operated under.
They enlisted the aid of William Brady,
the corrupt sheriff,
to enforce a fake court order that confiscated all of the horses and cattle on
the ranch.
When tunstall received the demands,
he thought it was some kind of mistake and proceeded to ride into town in order
to sort things out on the way there,
and he was met by the sheriff and a policy of men on their way to execute the
court order.
Still thinking he could reason with the Lumen to install road towards the
sheriff.
But before he got twice members of the policy,
they shot him dead.
To add insult to injury,
they shot his horse to install.
His body was soon found by the men who worked for him and taken back to his
ranch for burial.
Billy was incensed at the cold blooded assassination of his boss and he,
along with a group of hardcore other employees,
made a pact of vengeance against the house.
They made it to the top of which was the sheriff of Lincoln County.
William Brady Brady's ends came on April fool's day.
18,
78 says he was taking his morning stroll through Lincoln.
Billy and his fellow regulators were lying in ambush and poured more than a
dozen bullets into his body during the gunfight that ensued with Brady's
deputies.
Billy was shot in the thigh three days later.
A shootout occurred.
It blazes mill this time to have the regulators were killed as a result of the
two incidents,
several murder warrants were issued including one for billy.
The conflicts came to a head when Alexander Mcqueen road from the ton store
ranch with between 50 and 60 regulators on July the 14th,
18,
68.
Some of the men's strategically positioned themselves between buildings and on
rooftops while others including billy,
set themselves up in a house that belonged to McSweeney for the next two days.
They waited on July the 16th.
The new sheriff George happens,
send some men to kill the regular agency were stationed on the roof of the
saloon after one of them,
but was killed.
These men were forced to retreat.
Heaven.
Now send a message to fort stands in requesting military assistance.
The request was initially turned down,
but the military bras changed their mind the next day with that Nathan Dudley
road into town at the head of a troop of soldiers,
a standoff in sued for a couple more days.
Then on Friday,
July,
the 19th,
all hell broke loose.
The regulators were now all hold up in the house.
A massive barrage of firepower was unleashed on this house with return fire
coming just as fiercely.
Then the house was set on fire and then attempts to escape.
Alexander Mcswain was shot dead that he managed to kill the man who had felled
mcswain before making good on his own escape along with the other regulators.
Now,
just before we get into the rest of billy's life,
I do want to take a moment to thank the people who make this video possible and
that will be brilliant.
I know mid rollout is not great for the story here,
but these videos are long,
so I do hope you appreciate our needs to have sponsors to make them possible.
Brilliance.
Our lending platform,
which teaches three something called active learning,
unlike biographies,
which has done a nice way to learn about people's lives,
learning about science.
It's a bit trickier.
I don't know if you've ever had to sit down with a science textbook.
I have and I read them in a whole lot of stuff.
That makes me think,
hold on a second and then you ended up reading the page six times over and
you're still not taking it in.
Well,
brilliant.
Solves that problem with active learning,
Giving you something super short to read.
It's really easy and then you immediately apply it to a problem.
The rinse and repeat that and suddenly or understanding or sorts of stuff that
you really didn't think you'd be able to.
I've been using.
Brilliant and you should just go try it.
Just to see how easy it is to suddenly be understanding all of these complex
subjects.
It's really brilliant.
Just make them super easy to grasp.
You can support biographics by going to brilliant.org forward slash biographics,
and now let's get back to the kid.
Bye now developed into a seasoned killer.
He was now wanted for multiple counts of murder in different jurisdictions.
Still,
he was able to find refuge with the Hispanic sheepherders who viewed him as a
fighter for their liberty against the Anglo robber barons.
The firestorm that had erupted in the heart of Lincoln County forced authorities
to act in diamonds were issued for the arrest of billion to other regulators for
the murder of sheriff braiding.
I knew governor of New Mexico territory was also appointed the man given the job
was new wallace,
a format union,
army general and future author of the Book Ben Hart,
Wallace that Alpha Lincoln County with direct instructions from President
Rutherford b Hayes to restore order.
But while it's encountered a population who were too terrifying to get involved
in so was unable to secure any witness testimonies as to what had been
occurring,
that he received a letter from a man calling himself,
William H,
Bonnie.
The kids offered to testify against the members of the house in return for
philanthropists and swallows,
agreed,
believe,
testified before a grand jury with his testimony leading do indictments against
a number of house members including leader James Donut,
but he hadn't lived up to his side of the deal,
but unfortunately the governor did not live up to his skipping town before the
amnesty.
You could be formalized
with the governor gone.
Most of the indictments against the house members,
they would drops,
but those against the regulators,
they remained,
believe fled town before he could be arrested.
While the other regulars fled in New Mexico territory,
billy decided to stay put and you can also living as a council on Horse Rustler
over the next few months.
See arrestee ranches.
If the house empire and the process becoming the most wanted man in New Mexico,
the newspapers of New Mexico,
most of which were simply mouthpieces for the house,
demonized the blaming him for every misdeed in the territory in 18,
80,
the editor of the Las Vegas,
because that first names the outlawed,
believe the kids,
the name for which he would forever.
You know,
by the summer of 18,
80 though,
he still rooms the territory.
Billy had made a base for himself at Fort Sumner,
some 100 miles from Lincoln.
Why now?
Lincoln had a new sheriff and his name was pat garrison.
He was single minded with his obsession to capture billy the kid.
Garrett was a tenacious,
determined man.
He and his posse tractability and his gang over the winter of 18,
82 of the outlaws were killed in a shootout with the others being cornered in
cabinets,
a place called stinking springs.
After attempt standoff believe finally came out with his hands in the APP.
The kid was transported by train to Santa Fe and put on trial for the murder of
Sheriff Brady.
He was found guilty and sentenced to death by hanging the next and supposedly
last stop was Lincoln where he was housed in a second story room of the bank and
county courthouse.
It was there that he was to wait for his date with the news,
but well billy,
he had other plans on April the 28th,
18,
81 in the early afternoon.
Billing told us God that he needed to use the privy.
The guard escorted him in shackles to the outhouse on the way back as he went up
the stairs to his room,
but he managed to slip out of his hand and shackles.
He turns and wrestled with the gods,
managing to grab his gun.
The mountains tend to flee,
but believe shot him dead.
The kid then made for one of the rooms in which he knew there was a shotgun.
Quickly loading it.
He ran through a window and looked down on the street to see another God,
Bob [inaudible],
who had been eating his lunch across the way comes from wanting to investigate.
Billy called out hello barb,
before blasting him with both barrels with both gods,
dad,
billy.
Then race downstairs.
He commandeered a horse and was away,
but he's daring escape,
made them the most famous outlaw in the country,
but it also made him a three time cop killer.
This changed Garrett's mind now.
He wanted to hunt him down and kill him despite this,
and he chose to remain in New Mexico.
The reason being is that he had fallen in love with a 16 year old girl by the
name of polly to Maxwell back in Lincoln.
Garrett was receiving information as to the whereabouts of the kit.
They were being supplied by the older brother of police at peace maxwell who was
not happy about this romance.
He told Gary that billy was in Fort Sumner.
Garrett finally moved on the intelligence he stole into Fort Sumner on the
evening of July 14th,
1891 with two deputies alongside him.
They went straight to the home of the maxwells posting the two deputies on the
front porch.
She entered the house from the back and made for the bedroom of peet maxwell.
At this very moment that he was approaching the porch in the dark,
he could only just make out the shape of the two men there and he called out who
is it,
but there was no reply at this belly.
Cautiously backs through the open doorway inside garrison maxwell were sitting
on the bed on seeing the figure.
Maxwell leaned over and whispered to him garret levels,
his six shooter and fired.
Then either kids fell,
dad's never knowing who had fired the fatal bullet,
so I really hope you found this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
Brand new videos just like this two times a week.
Also,
do checkout brilliance.
You'll find a link to them in the description below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.